there is limited dignity on the front
line
as india records its highest daily
number of deaths
thousands more are struggling to breathe
oxygen remains the highest form of
currency as hospitals grapple with
demand
the uk government now stepping up its
response
i've been talking to foreigner we want
to make sure we provide the help that
they really need so we're listening very
carefully
so on top of the concentrators the
oxygen concentrators
the oxygen generators we're now
providing an additional a thousand
ventilators
to support our indian friends in there
in their time of most need
with the western world's vaccine
programs thriving india the biggest
exporter of those jabs
is on its knees which for labour is
leaving a bitter taste
we were woefully unprepared and we had
to appeal to the rest
of the world for help and india stepped
forward to prove the export
of huge amounts of paracetamol to the uk
because we're in danger
of running out so there are long and
deep ties between us and india that mean
that we should step up
aid and support continues to arrive as
the world unites to help a country in
need
as welcome as it is some in the uk say
it is simply
not enough and are taking matters into
their own hands
i think everyone needs to do more to
help this virus doesn't care what
politics are
what color you are what religion you are
it's attacking human beings and we need
to
uh tackle it as human beings as one
please yes thank you the south asian
population in berkshire feeling
compelled to help
many from this charity have family
affected teachers rina and groushara
today delivering
five ventilators fundraised by a west
london school
just to see the number of funerals that
are taking place
it just breaks my heart their life
matters
they're not just like things they're
human beings and why are we just closing
our eyes on that we shouldn't be
every day india is waking up to more
death and more mourning
there are growing calls for greater
collective action for a country
which is crying out for help ashna
harinag
sky news